♪♪
- I'm glad you're back.
I'm just gonna take some time
gettin' used to.
You just gotta get yourself
back out there.
- Oh, my.
You were All-USA player two
years in a row at Riverside?
- Yes, sir.
A whole lot's changed.
- That boy? That's Sam.
His momma took off.
He'll be stayin' with us 'till she's back.
- You know you're a boy, right?
- Yeah.
♪ In the hours that I've known ♪
- Do you know when
my mom is coming back?
- He's gonna have to go in the system.
- There's somethin'
seriously wrong with that kid.
♪ Would you set me free? ♪
- How did you end up in prison?
- Don't matter.
I did what I did.
- But look at what you did today.
♪ And there's nowhere to hide ♪
- Listen to me, son.
Kids are mean.
Especially when they see something
that they ain't used to seein'.
- You ain't nothin' but a criminal.
You got no right looking after any child.
♪ Just set me free ♪
- There's things in this world you can be,
and there's things that you can't.
How many boys do you see on that show?
- None.
- What does that tell you?
- That I can be the first.
- Trick or treat!
- Hi! Get some treats.
- The truth is, I haven't felt
like I was good at anything...
♪ Just set me free ♪
- ...until Sam.
♪ Keep running 'till
they learn to find peace ♪
♪ Just set me free ♪
- Shelly came back.
(Sam shouting)
- Get off of me!
- Hey!
- What--
- Couldn't stay out of trouble, could ya?
♪ Just set me free ♪
- Palmer!
- I can't abandon that boy.
♪ Just set me free ♪
- I will not abandon that boy.
- Heard y'all had a little
tea party the other day.
- Ooh, yeah.
- Careful, Palmer. It's hot.
- Pinkies, please.
- Mm.
- Yes.
- Mm, real good.